next speaker the session is a how it's
Robin what college you will telling we
will be telling us about expressive
power of two very large well thank you
I'd like to thank the organizers for the
kind invitation does this forced me to
actually calculate and sail out how many
years ago I was a graduate student here
but it's okay so this talk lives in
first order logic onwards interpreting
words over a finite alphabet there is
this one relation less than that lets
you say that one position is to the left
of another and using this you can define
properties of words you can define
languages so for example this one here
the sentence says there's two positions
there's a letter a in both of those
positions and this part here says that
there's no position strictly between
them so you put it together this sense
defines a regular language if you think
of the input alphabet as a bee this
sends defines the regular language
consisting of all the words that have
two consecutive days and just some facts
about what you can do in this logic I'm
concentrating on one kind of result here
so not things like the complexity of
deciding if a formula is true but just
to start off with every language that
you can define in this logic of course
is a regular language there is an
alternative equivalent characterization
in terms of temporal logic everything
that you can define here is these are
exactly the languages definable and when
you're propositional temporal logic
there is a hierarchy within this based
on alternation of quantifiers and that
hierarchy is infinite because it means
that for every k as long as the alphabet
has at least two letters for every km
there are languages here of arbitrarily
large alternation depth they're outside
of Sigma K and the kind of result that
I'm going to concentrate on the most
oh here it is it is is this one that you
can decide whether a given regular
language say it's given by regular
expression given by a finite automaton
is definable in this logic this is was
an old result from the 1960s do two
shits in birthday and this is the this
is the kind of result that I most
interested in this for in this talk so
for first-order logic to give you the
example these algebraic decision
procedures are based on the syntactic mo
noid of the language what you do is you
construct the minimal DFA for the
language and you look at the transitions
on the set of states that are induced by
the words this forms a finite semigroup
of Pi night Mon oi because it has an
identity under composition and for the
example that we saw before the set of
words that contain two consecutive days
if you tabulate it you'll find out that
there are actually exactly six elements
here and these equations by the way
completely determine the multiplication
of words in this mo annoyed and a
language is definable in first order
logic if and only if this mo annoyed
contains no nontrivial groups that
should some days result equivalent way
to say this the word for this is that
the mo noida is a periodic you can also
express this in terms of identities i'll
use this symbol a lot inside a finite
semigroup every element has a power
that's an idempotent there's unique item
potent among the powers of X and we'll
to know that by X 0 X to the Omega so
another way to say that the Monod is a
periodic is that it satisfies this
equation in the particular case of this
one example this collapse is 2x cubed
equals x squared for every excellent
alright so this is a sort of game that
I'm going to play with the two variable
fragment you get these equations and the
way to tell whether or not a language is
definable in this logic is to do this
kind of computation of the finite
semigroup ok so in first order logic
with this less than relation every
sentence is equivalent to one that uses
only three variables you
reuse the variables this result was
actually appears in Kemps work on the
propositional on linear temporal logic
because in translating from temporal
logic into first-order logic this found
that you only need three variables so
different proof by a merman and cozen
the uses of model theoretic techniques
with the model theoretic games um and
we'll do this denote by with this
superscript to the fragment consisting
of formulas where you only use two
variables and for example to see how
this works them I always get these wrong
so I think I check this is that this is
a set of words over the alphabet a B
that the letter immediately after the
first day is also an a so it contains an
A and right after that there's an A and
you can save this with two variables by
saying there's a position that contains
an a somewhere to the left of its
somewhere the left of it there's an A
and furthermore for every wide to the
left of it that's a B everything to the
left of that is also would be in other
words it can't be any bees between these
two ways so there's no direct way to say
in this logic that one position is
strictly between another one position is
a successor of another but you can sort
of sneak up on it for this example on
the other hand our original example of
the set of words that contain two
consecutive days this cannot be defined
in this logic and we'll see why in a
moment so um
this is not advancing for me it was
working of before when I see that the
one on the right all right so let's see
do I have to do this the old-fashioned
way of the computer of their now it's
working good oh did you do that or did I
do it I didn't okay all right good ya
know I had that maybe I wasn't just like
leaning on it hard enough thank you the
so here are some facts about this is
mostly from papers by most of this from
papers by at the Sami Vardy vilkin
tarigan not all the same paper there's a
few of them one is that as for full
first-order logic with the lesson
relation and this has an alternate
characterization in temporal logic where
you just have these future and past
modalities this is a formula that
denotes the same example that I had
before and there's a lot of other
characterizations in terms of air in
five games with just two pebbles in turn
Zaranth waste games with just one pebble
because as long as you keep track of
which direction the move was made in
things called rankers and turtle
language is not sure what those are like
what's new and also if you look at where
does this sit inside the quantifier
alternation hierarchy inside the larger
logic inside first order where you're
allowed more than two variables it's
actually all sitting down in a low level
it's inside Sigma 2 and in fact it's
exactly the intersection of Sigma 2 and
PI 2 and finally as they say this is the
kind of result are most interested in
there's an algebraic decision procedure
for define ability and that's at a
regular language is definable in this
logic if and only if well there's some
condition on the syntactic mo annoyed
again this is a more complicated
condition but that it belongs to this
class da
okay okay it did didn't move oh okay I
wasn't looking so the what I have to do
is not look when i press the button
invented that meets ago okay so there's
many equivalent characterizations of
this class of finite Mona with lots of
different equations in terms of the
ideal structures the easiest thing in
the easiest equation is this one that
for any two elements x and y this
equation is satisfied remember that
Omega means the item potent power and um
so you know you can just plug things
into this and you get the the result
whether it's definable or not so in the
example that we have before of the set
of words that contain two consecutive
days if you just look at the calculation
that was done before replace x and y by
a and b respectively then a be the item
potent power of a B is just a V but if
you insert a name this evaluate the
left-hand side of that equation you get
a different element you get the zero and
that's the way you use this to prove
that this cannot be expressed using two
variables and moreover if it does
satisfy the equation then there is a way
to write a sentence for it so the
formula that we okay so this is about
alternation depth alternatives in depth
i was talking about originally in terms
of first-order logic without the
restriction on variables for it when you
restrict the number of variables it
doesn't make sense to talk about a
prefix anymore because you're going to
be reusing variables on the other hand
it does make sense to talk about
alternation depth if you like push all
of the negations to the level of the
atomic formulas and just count the
number of alternations of quantifiers on
any path from I guess the root of the
tree representing this formula down to
the leaves so in this one there's a the
longest path is this exists for all for
all so there's one alternation will
counting the number of blocks not
actually the number of alternations so
this has alternation depth too and
there's some natural questions asked
here one is in this restricted logic is
the quantifier ultra
of hierarchy infinite and also the same
kind of question that was asked before
it can you actually decide this question
can you just look at the language and
find out what the exact alternation
depth is and the answer for the first
one whether the alternation depth
hierarchy is finite or infinite is yes
and no and the yes and no is this is a
result of vicen immerman there are
languages of arbitrarily large
alternation depth however if you
restrict the alphabet to a fixed finite
alphabet then the alternation depth is
bounded depending on the size of the
alphabet I discovered with horror this
morning as I was going over the talk
that I had a number of off by one errors
in the statement of this I think this is
the right statement isn't it it's close
enough right yeah that's that's actually
the way I felt about it but I didn't
want to you know I want it I want to get
it right of it okay the other question
which is whether you can effectively
determine the exact quantifier
alternation depth of hot in this
hierarchy in other words is there
something that looks like one of these
algebraic decision procedures again by
the way you can prove by a kind of
abstract nonsense argument that all of
these properties really depend only on
these algebraic invariants they only
depend on the syntactic moaning but it's
another story to find out exact
equations in the leg so the answer here
is yes and this is from a few years ago
2013 maybe and actually done they're two
completely different answers here the
two different algebraic decision
decision procedures different criteria
and they were discovered independently
I'll show you the one that I know this
is a and it actually is a system of
equations so I realize this is a little
bit hard to read but it's a sequence of
equations and it starts out with these
using just two unknowns in the equation
u1 equals v1 where u 1 and V 1 are
defined this way and then at each step
you introduce two new variables and
build these new words use of n plus 1
and V sub n plus 1 over u sub N and visa
min and in this
wait you get this whole big sequence of
equations and a language is definable in
two variable logic with quantifier dip
less than or equal to and if and only if
the syntactic Mona is a periodic and
that means it has no nontrivial groups
inside and it satisfies this equation u
sub N equals V sub in and just in
contrast so that gives a nice criterion
for this the analogous problem for
quantifier alternation depth if you
don't have this variable restriction is
a very long open problem there was this
recent breakthrough just a few years ago
x + + zaytoun that decides membership in
sigma 3 and the boolean closure sigma 2
I think there's also an argument for
Sigma 4 but this is a very difficult
much more difficult than what's done for
the two variable logic and still an open
problem for the other levels ok all
right let's see
okay I don't know it's just maybe i'm
holding in some funny way you know the
magic she said you do this you know
that's not good next yeah right it's
like the page turner for the piano
player yeah we use some more reliable
okay question question yes it's that
equation you and equal to the end is
exercisable sure and the reason it's
decidable is this it's just explicit if
you have the moat for any of these
equations if you're the multiplication
table of the Mon I'd written down you
just plug in values I mean in principle
you have to try out all combinations and
values but it's definitely decidable and
it's you can even bound the complexity
for something and not too unreasonable
there as well this one's not working
either okay well I condemn I can just do
it the old-fashioned way yeah okay good
so I'm those equations actually give
another proof of the strictness of the
hierarchy I'm just to show you what an
argument like this would look like to
define a congruence son on a star and
the set of words over eight the
definition is a little bit fussy to
write down the whole thing correctly but
just in a nutshell don't read all this
here's the way it works you look at the
word you read it from left to right and
look at the first occurrence of the last
letter to occur so in this case the
letters in the word or a B and C and you
read from left to right the last
occurrence is the first occurrence last
letter to appear is the sea and the
prefix is VAB you read from the right to
the left and the last the first
occurrence of the last letter to appear
when you read in this direction is the B
so you get the see here this prefix of
the be here this suffix and you say that
two words are equivalent if these
quadruples map up in the following sense
that you get the same letter here and
here and that the corresponding prefixes
and suffixes are also congruent and the
reason this actually works as it's a
recursive definition add breeze by
induction on the size of the alphabet so
this defines the congruence for example
for words over three letter alphabet in
terms of a tool
alphabet the induction starts at zero so
that's the congruence and the quotient
by this Congress this is actually a
well-known construction this is the free
item potent monoi done a its hide every
element in is it idempotent so it
satisfies this identity here and using
that it's actually pretty easy in terms
of the description of the congruence to
show that each congruence class is
defined by a two variable formula and
the alternation depth is equal to the
size of the alphabet and furthermore if
you look at the equations we have for
characterizing alternation depth since
everything is idempotent this one I'd
all those omegas go away and you want
envy when then look like this you can
see these two words are not congruent
over this two letter alphabet x1 x2
because here x1 is the first letter to
appear and here express letter to appear
and as you go up the scale you find that
the word ska responding to you too and
v2 are not congruent come over a
four-letter alphabet over a six letter
alphabet for you three and v3 and the
reason these two words are not congruent
is that in both cases the first letter
to appear when you're reading from left
to right is x 4 and then if you take
that prefix the first letter to appear
reading from right to left as x3 and
that would then imply that you one has
to be congruent to v1 over the smaller
alphabet and it's not so if you have a
pair that's not Congress you build them
up this way and you get other pairs that
or not and this shows that if you
alphabet has 2n letters in a congruence
class for this congruence is not
definable and you can actually get that
too when down to n plus 2 by using a
slightly different congruence it's also
possible using this algebraic method to
get another proof of the other result of
vice Zimmerman that this hierarchy
collapses for a fixed finite alphabet a
because the if the monoid is generated
by n elements it's possible to change
the equation for any k great use of K
equals V sub K for any K greater than it
actually implies that the equation holds
for in as well
so I'm going to change this logic a
little bit I haven't said anything about
this thing that if you had a successor
relation you can define more stuff
almost everything works the same way
there's a counterpart in temporal logic
that is bounded alternation depth with
respect to the larger logic there is an
algebraic decision procedure for define
ability the hierarchy strict I don't
think you get the collapsed result in
the same way for this one I don't know
it's different with successor because ok
I'll just look I'm not sure about that
but what I do want to do in the last few
minutes is talk about the actual new
work that's here so why is what's the
difference between two variable logic
and the full first-order logic and
basically if you try to put your finger
on it is because in two variable ah jik
you cannot say that one position is
between two other positions yes oh yeah
so what happens if you add a relation
that says there is an a between
positions x and y in other words you add
a another relation with two free
variables like this that says there's
some position Z strictly between x and y
that contains an eight and then you can
define the successor relation if you do
that you can define the language we saw
at the beginning of this talk and we'll
use this notation first-order logic with
two variables but where you've added
this between relation and just to give a
rundown of what's here um so the obvious
question is do you recover all of
first-order logic this way the answer is
no the another way to say it more
positively it's this logic is still
strictly contained in there and it's
this is an example that separates and
I'll see in a moment why that is is the
quantifier alternation depth the so
called dot depth of languages in this
logic bounded and the answer again is no
but it's sort of a qualified no because
once again this depends on the size of
the alphabet if we use the as the
letters of the alphabet symbols for n +
or at different depths then and then
take the set of prefix and coatings of
death and boolean circuits
that evaluate to true then what you find
actually is that this language has
alternation depth larger than n it's not
in Sigma n on the other hand this
requires the alphabet to grow and we
believe that if you fix the alphabet
size that the quantifier alternation
depth in this sense is bounded but we've
only been able to prove that for a two
letter alphabet it's really kind of our
open question and finally yes we do have
one of these well we have an algebraic
decision procedure but again it's not as
tight a result as we'd like it is a
necessary condition that we can compute
we know this condition is sufficient for
two letter alphabets and we're still
working on the question about for larger
alphabets so the condition is this it's
a little involved but there's this thing
called the J ordering on finite
semigroups that m1 is jb low em two of
em one belongs to the two-sided ideal
generated by m2 and what you do is you
take for each item potent you take the
sub Mon I generated by elements that are
J above the item potent that you can
form a another Mon oyed inside the
monoid and the criterion is that this
little moan oh it is NBA so I'll try to
wrap it up the that what this lets you
do is do these simple calculations for
instance this is the minimal DFA of this
language it's an incompletely specified
DFA so it doesn't have that sink state
the elements of the monoid are these
partial functions and you just do a
calculation here you can verify that
that condition about the EMS of e's is
doesn't hold for this because it's
violet just evaluate the underlying
equations and this we know that this
cannot be defined in the given logic and
there's a picture here this is a picture
for all alphabets there would we think
there's a different picture if you
restrict the finite alphabet of where
these different logics like relative to
the alternation high
the nfo less than i'm going to say one
word with five words about the way we do
this I haven't said anything about the
pier I'm going to skip these ones um I'm
gonna skip items and anything about the
proofs but the deal here is that showing
that an equation is one of these
conditions is necessary is actually kind
of easy easy really belongs in quotes
here it's easier than the converse it's
actually possible to do this with an
errand boys game kind of argument
usually we pass through something
different we start out with the logical
description and translate it into a
description in terms of something like
semi direct product decompositions and
the like but showing sufficiency of an
equation is usually much harder and
that's seems to be a different kind of
argument in each case and that's where
most of the work is involved in these
things and um so I sort of wanted to
finish by saying I this is not
necessarily what I want to be doing but
it's all I know how to do and the that
it has to do with a limitation of this
this approach this is actually pretty
cool this is this algebraic method is
it's a really powerful tool for
characterizing deciding expressive power
of logics but it only is powerful in
this limited domain where their logics
on words that define only regular
languages so if you move that barrier a
little bit for instance for regular
languages of trees are so promising
results I think you can even do two
variable logic but although there is a
machinery in place for doing this it's
much much harder to squeeze interesting
results out of this it'll also be very
interesting to try to characterize the
regular languages in extensions these
logics which should let you define non
regular languages and these are
equivalent to a number of problems in
circuit complexity again there's going
to be at least one talk about this this
meaning but this is a big challenge and
these things that remain major
challenges okay so I'm done thank you
yes you gave you a hard example for our
donation you mentioned the freakum
idempotent yes is there some way of
making this relationship with the
idempotent on fo two more exactly a
higher level thing fo to is idempotent
uh I'm okay not sure I understand the
question a te even even even so I'll
answer it about them so that congruence
that's used to define the free item
potent monoid there's a way of
generalizing the congruence where you're
looking at things like the second or the
third appearance or something like that
at a letter and you get a whole sequence
of congruence is this way and that's
equivalent to da so that will define the
whole variety that way bye-bye kind of
tweaking that definition you get you get
the whole variety I don't know that that
answers the question but this Nick but
but yeah I mean there's a there's sort
of a generalization of that congruence
it gives you the result other questions
well oriole form yes no let's say how
are ya